こんにちは最後のスピーカーになりました
皆さんごきげんいかがですか
ゆるく始まってますけれどあのいろんな話
を聞いてきていろんなことが皆さんの中に
も動いているんじゃないかなと思ってい
ますちょっと大切な問いからスタートさせ
てください今日これまでいろんな話を聞い
てきていろんなことが心の中で頭の中で
渦巻いているんじゃないかと思います
たくさんの刺激ありましたよね
このフリップチャートアメリカで通ってき
た写真ですが僕のとても大事な先生
ピーターソンエンゲさんがやっている
ワークショップでいつもこんな問いが
投げかけられるんです
上から2行目ですねワップリング
私たちをここに連れてくるものって何です
か
あなたはどうしてここに来ましたかって
いう問いなんです
皆さんどうですか今日いろんな刺激を受け
てみて振り返ってみてどうしてここに来
られました
いろんな理由があると思うんです友達が
チケットを売ってたとかFacebook
で見かけてとか福ちゃん久しぶりやから
ちょっと賑やかしたろうとか言ったらその
いろんな外的な要因の他に私の中にも理由
があったと思いませんあ
テレックス京都であんねんって面白いな見
に行こうって時に私何か期待してるから私
来るんですよね
友達がチケットを売っているあそれに応え
てあげようってその外的な要因に答える
とき私の中にあこの子いい子やしとか普段
頑張ってるしでこの子が普段大事にしてる
ものどんなんか知りたいなっていう好奇心
とか
その私の中にある今日皆さんをここに来
させたものそこにちょっと目を向けて
ほしいんです
時間を
少しだけ取ります自分自身に問いかけて
あげてください
私たちをあるいは私を今日ここに連れてき
たものってなんですか
何が私をここに連れてきましたか
どんな気持ち何か大切にしてること
期待とか
今から1分だけ時間を取ります
隣の人とそれを話してみて欲しいんです
皆さんをここに来させたもの私をここに
連れてきたものって何ですか
何とかさんが言うててんって外の理由じゃ
なく私が期待してたこと願ってたこと大切
にしてたこと一言で構いませんちょっと隣
の人と
交換してみてください
1分間
待ちます計りますじゃあ皆さんどうぞ
ざわざわざわって
はいありがとうございます
ずっと聞きっぱなしやったところで自分で
声を出してみてどうですかどんな感覚が
ありますこれチェックインと呼ばれます
この場に少し自分自身がどんな状態でいる
のか声に出してもらうこともう一つ大事な
の聞いてもらうことなんですよねそんな風
にして僕はこの学びが起きる場所っていう
のを先生たち向けに時には子供たち向けに
あるいは一般のビジネスの人たち
企業の人たち向けにやっています
私です寝隣に写っているのがさっき少し
名前に出たピーター宣言先生この人から
教えてもらった事っていうのを僕は
いろんな場所で
オンラインでとかオフラインでとかそして
子供向けにとかいろんな場所で伝えていく
知ってもらうでこんな風に一緒に場を共に
しながら学んでいくということをやってい
ます
皆さん今何が私をここに連れてきました
かってお互い話し合ってみてどんな話が出
ました
いろんな期待があると思うんですよね
面白い話が聞きたかった何で聞きたかっ
たかっていうとそれを聞くことで私の日常
に何か変化があるかもしれへんとか
ちょっと日々を期待に満ちた気持ちで
暮らしたいとか
あるいはいろんなアイディア聞くことで
ちょっとしたことから世界が変わるって
思いたいとかそのいろんな気持ちと同時に
なんか内なる声が聞こえてくると思いませ
ん
運命主義っています
セイタリズム」って英語で言うんです物事
はもともと決まっていて私たちには変え
られないできることはそんなにないって
いう思い込みのことなんです
この言葉が学習する組織っていう本の中に
出てきてその言葉を言ったのこの人
ムバリング無視してさんっていうウガンダ
の地域の開発のリーダーやった人ですこの
人が言ったんですってアフリカの開発の
いきなり何でアフリカの話やねんて思うか
もしれませんそのうち繋がるから聞いとい
てくださいねアフリカの開発の一番の障害
が何かっていうと人がないことお金がない
こと技術がないことじゃないねんって
それは運命主義なん
やもちろんさんは関西弁で喋ってないと
思うんですけれど言ってることはね
いろんな人たちが助けようとするんですよ
貧しい人たちを困った人たちを何とか助け
てあげようとしてプログラムが組まれてお
金が費やされて人がやってきて状況
ちょっと改善した後その人たちが去って
いくと状況また元に戻るんですよね
いろんな人たちがいいこと言って何とか
しようと思ってちょっと改善した後全部元
に戻ってしまうこれ繰り返していく中で
アフリカの人々の心の中に一つの思い込み
無意識の考えがどんどん積み上げられて
いったそれ
フェイタリズムと言うんです
助けというのは外部からやってくるもので
ある
私たちは誰かに救われる存在である誰かが
いいこと言って良いプログラムを持ってき
てくれることでしか私たちは救われなくて
私たちに自分自身の未来を作る力は
ないすごい聞いてて悲しい話ですけれど
その気持ち私たちの中にありません
いろんな話を聞いて面白いなやってみよう
かと同時にいやいやいやいやでもそんな
ことやっても無駄やでって変わらんよ世界
はとか
政治はとか教育はとか
組織って絶対変わらへんねんとかいや
そんなことやって何なんでそんなん
ちっちゃい取り組みやんけっていろんな
いろんなこの皮肉屋の声が僕らの中にある
と思いません
これフェイタリズム」って言うんです
このフェリズムが蔓延する状態ここに欠け
ているものがリーダーシップやって僕の
先月さんは言うんですね
リーダーシップこれまた僕苦手な言葉でし
た何がリーダーやねんって偉そうにしてっ
てすごい校舎に構えてたんですこのリー
ドって言葉の意味を知るまでは
ここで言ってるリーダーシップとかリー
ダーって言葉これえらい人とか役職高い人
って意味じゃないんです皆さんリードとか
リーダーという言葉について考えてみた
ことありますかあると思いますけれど
いろんなこと言われてますよねで一般的に
僕らがリーダーのこと語るとき誰の話して
ます
役職高い人のことですよね別名ボスですよ
ね上司でも皆さん残念ながらこんなこと心
の中で思ったことありませんあの上司は
全然リーダーじゃないって
高い役職についている政治家をとか
企業の偉い人を指さしてあの人には
リーダーシップがないとかあんな人
リーダーちゃうって心の中でこう呟いた
ことありません
多くの人あるんですよねでも考えてみると
これおかしいと思いません
リーダーっていうのが役職高い人の話やっ
たらあの人はリーダーじゃないってのあの
人とやっぱり高い役職についていける高い
役職の人ちゃうでって
めっちゃ矛盾した話ですよね
リードっていう言葉の語源リードの
リーダーってこれ役職のことだけじゃない
んですその人の性質ですリーダーって
どんな人でしょう
難しい
意思決定していく人
危険の中でリスクを取って前に進む人
不確実なわけのわからへん今みたいの
世の中の中で何かを決めて未来に向けて
進む人そんなイメージありません
これリードって言葉の語源なんです
leiphってスペルしますインド
ヨーロッパ系の古い言葉でその意味これな
んです
境界線を越えて前に進むこと
今いる場所私が今安全で有能でここでやっ
たらどうしたらいいかよくわかる場所から
そうじゃないところに境界線を越えて
踏み出すとき
私たちはリーダーシップを発揮してるん
です
どうなるかわからないリスクがいっぱい
ある不安があるいろんな人がやめとけって
いう中でだけど私にとってはこれが大切
やっていうものに向けて一歩進むこと
これリードって言葉なんです
そんな事例をたくさんのトークの中にあり
ましたよね
でそして
このリーダーシップについて僕大したこと
やってませんいろんな人に比べて本当に
少しのことしかやってないと思います
いろんな人の学びの場を作ってますこの
自分のストーリーちょっとだけシェアさせ
てください
私この先月先生にうちの父親からその名前
を教わって会うことになります
そしていろんな縁がつながって仕事を
手伝わしてもらうんですねアメリカで3
年間一緒にいてでその間にこの先家さんが
ずっと言うんですビジネスの分野で有名に
なったこの学習する組織っていう本を書き
システム思考を提唱してきた人が大事なの
は教育や教育や教育やって言うんですよね
私たちの民主主義のクオリティ民主主義の
質というのは公教育の質にかかっている
私たちは学校っていう場所にこの社会の
未来を投資してるんやって言われてみたら
その通りなんですけど僕ピンと来なかった
んですそれまで教育について考えたこと
なかった
ところが2016年姪っ子が生まれます
初めてのメインやったんです
めちゃくちゃ可愛くってでもなんかこう
ずーっと何にもできないただその存在自体
が愛おしくてふと気づくんですよねあこの
子が
6歳から18歳まで12年間僕ら自身が
そうしてきたようにこの子供の頃いろんな
価値観を身につけていく中ですごい
たくさんの時間を教育学校の中で過ごすん
ですよね
なんかせなあかん
そしたらそれと時を同じくしてこの先月
先生真ん中写ってますけれどその教育者
向けのワークショップに初めて出る機会が
出てきます80人の教育者がこのどうやっ
て学んでいく組織を作っていくか
チームよりより良い存在にしていって
教育のシステムを変えていくって話をし
てるんですよ
感動するんですねその姿を見た途端その
言葉を聞いた瞬間にあーってこれだけ
たくさんの人たちがこんな思いを持って
このいろんなツールを共に学びながらこの
ややこしいシステムを私たちを取り巻く
この教育というものを変えていくって
つぶやいて
いるもしそんな場所が小中高と存在して
姪っ子がそこで育っていくならば
姪っ子18歳の頃にどんな世界が見えると
思います僕がやっていたような科目をただ
覚えていく勉強ではなくってグループ
ワークやりながらプロジェクトをやり
ながら今日のこの場所も京都芸術大学の
学生さんたちが作ってくれてますこの実際
の世界とつながりながらいろんな
プロジェクトをやって対話をして
コンフリックと経験しながらその中で学ん
でいくそれが小学校からもしも起きるなら
ば18歳になる皆さんの後に続く次の世代
にどんな社会が見えると思います
希望だらけじゃないですか
僕もうこれ何かしないといけないって確信
するんですよねそしてこのシステム思考を
学習する組織の考え方を伝えていきたいと
思った時に
通常やったらどう考えると思います
どうやったら教育変わるかなですよね
私たち何かを変えるという考え方にすごく
慣れ親しんでいます
危険なんですこれ私が自分の奥さん
変えようとすると失敗するんです皆さん
経験ありますよね自分の家族息子とか娘と
かパートナーあるいは親とかを
作戦立てて変えようとしてうまくいった人
いますありえないですよね
でも思いません学校変わっていくとか組織
が変わっていく社会変わっていくて私たち
人間が変わっていくっていうことなんです
よね
私たちはまるで物を扱ってものの部品を
変えていくかのようなアプローチを使って
この人間世界を変えようとするおかしい話
じゃないですか
僕変えようとするのをやめましたこれも
教わったんです先生に生きた世界において
変化を育みたいならば家族の中に夫婦の中
に教室の中に人間関係の中に変化を
作り出したいならば知っておきなさいって
教育を変えようじゃなくって変化は副産物
や
こんな話なんです
変化って自然界にずっと起きてるんですね
私たちの体も変わり続けているどんな風に
私たちの体は新しい細胞を作り続けること
で変わり続けているんです
私たちの体は今あるこの細胞を別の細胞に
作り変えたりしません
自然界に起きている変化というのは何かを
変えることではなく新しいものを
育んでいくことによって起きているんです
うちの庭に白い花が咲いてたそこに赤い花
がやってきてそれが増えていくときに
まるで庭白かった庭が赤くなるかのような
変化が副産物として起きてくるんですよね
そう思った時僕がやるべきことっていうの
は学びの場を育んでいくことでした
いろんな熱になる先生当時全然知らなかっ
たんですけどとにかく興味持ってもらえる
人に会い続けますそしてこんな話あんねん
ちょっと聞いてって言って
継続して
継続して学ぶ場所を作っていきますで
気づくんです僕ら普段学びってこんな風に
捉えるんですよねなんか練習してみてあと
はそれを実践するだけやねんてでも実際
そんな風に変化が起きていなかったこれ
まるで何かを変えてやるみたいな話なん
です僕がやらんかった事っていうのは
育んでいくことやったんですややこしい図
が出てきてますけれど見てほしいのは
R1って書いてある左下のとこだけです
そこが僕のやることやったんです
一緒に集まって深い話ができる場所を作る
ことそこに話が深まるようなツールとして
これまで学んできたようなツールを提供
することシェアすること
そしたらそこで先生たち同士仲良くなって
いくんですね
ずっと熱意があったんですその人が
もともとリーダーシップなかったんじゃ
なくいろんな思いがある中でややこしい
現実の中で葛藤している先生たちが一緒に
あって対話をしていろんなことに気づいて
いくその仲間がいる時にいろんなこと試し
ていけるようになっていくんですよね
僕はこれをやり続けるって自分の
経験と知恵とそしてこれから学んでいく
ことを通じていろんな変化を育むために
自分自身を使うんです
そしたら
そしていきたいと思いますがまた心の声が
やってくるんですよね僕の中にずっと救っ
ているフェイタリズムが運命主義がそれで
間に合うのってお前そんなちっちゃいこと
しかできへんのって
そんなんでほんまに変化が起きますかって
ありませんそんな声何かやってみようこれ
いいアイディアかもしれへんって思うと
同時に自分の中にこの皮肉屋がやってくる
んですよね
その時に思い出す言葉があるんです
それを1個紹介して
閉じようと思っていますというかいい加減
閉じないといけない時間になっています
あのねマザー
テレサの言葉なんです
このピーター先生の友達がマザーテレサに
会った時にこう聞いたそうなんです
どうやったら偉大な仕事ができますかって
どうやったら大きい仕事ができるんです
かってそんな立派な仕事どうやったらでき
ますかって聞いた
そしたらマザーテレサがその質問の意味が
わからないという感じでポカーンとしたん
ですってこの人誰だったかな
一体何を言ってんねん
どうしたんかなとか思ったらマザーテレサ
突然あーってあーわかったって
こう言ったそうなんです
あのねって
大きな仕事なんて
偉大な仕事なんてできませんよっ
て小さなことをやるんです大きな愛を込め
て
僕らは
皮肉屋の声っていうのはそれで十分ですか
そんなことやって意味ありますかって僕ら
のやってやろうとしていることできるかも
しれへんことっていうのをいやいやそんな
ことやっても意味ないよって潰してくるん
ですよねただ僕ら
与えられてる体これだけなんです出る声
これだけですこれを使って小さいことやる
んですそれだけですよね
いつまでって生きてる限りでそれ以上でき
ませんから声も出なくなります
そうやって心底好きなことをやる心から
大切に思うことをやるその時に
いいことがあるんです
私たち仲間に出会います
本当に大切に思っていることを大切に思っ
てくれる深いつながりを持った仲間が
できるんです
長いだ合わなくても変わらないって絶対
大丈夫って思えるようなその深い関係性を
持った仲間が生まれていくときに私は自分
のできることやりますよって好きなこと
やってますからねそしてできなくなったら
終わりです
でも全然心配がありませんだって私には
つながっている仲間がたくさん存在する
から
僕がこの仕事を終えてもいいんですいつ
降りても構いませんできなくなったならだ
けどそうやって対話を繰り返してきた一緒
に場所を作ってきたこの人に背中を押して
もらったから頑張れんねんってそんな
繋がりがある時に僕らはずっとその仕事を
続けていくことができるんですこの体を
捨ててでも僕が僕が亡くなった後でもその
仕事は続くんです
そこに自分を使うだけ大事な目的のために
好きなことのために私を使いましょ
偉大な仕事なんてできません一人の人間
です小さなことやるんです大きな愛を込め
て
皆さんにいろんな大きな小さなことがある
ことを願ってますありがとうございました
[拍手]